[Music]
[Applause]
hey all diegetic aerosol imports disgust
degra shadows GMO AKA garbage neil
obstruction
oh dear debbie i think you've got the
wrong idea when it comes to GMOs yes
they've been given a really bad rep but
there's actually a lot of scientific
research out there to suggest that they
are not that bad
but let's get real GMOs are dangerous
they're caught everything from flood
keyways and talkin barks I mean welcome
to Kansas City whoa hang on there Debbie
before you go signaling the May Day
alerts let's break it down
so GMOs have actually been shown helps
no resistance to certain tests diseases
and environmental conditions which is
ultimately better for everyone in fact a
2014 meta-analysis that measure the
economic impact of genetically modified
crops found that they were able to
reduce pesticide use by about 37 percent
and increase crop yield by 22 percent
and increase profits by 68 percent
that's huge and while you may think
we're talking about big farm here we're
also talking about those local and
generational farms you know those
farmers who rely on their crops to feed
their families and ultimately their
communities like you Debbie a bigger
time but I heard the GMOs kill Cross
instantly I know Debbie Ashley there's
some research out there to suggest that
GMOs may help promote longer shelf life
and delay spoilage which is great for a
reduction in food waste also studies
show that GMOs may help with global food
supply demands which trust me buddy
that's going to be key for the growing
population that's nice give open a low
in nutrients right look at these lemon
non-gmail GMO
[Music]
that is a huge misconception and
probably one of the biggest concerns
when it comes to GMOs but there's some
kind of frankenfoods with no nutritional
value
well after dozens of years and analyzing
the safety of GMOs a review of 33
studies found that GMOs were no less
healthy or safe than their traditionally
grown counterparts in fact in some cases
they might even be healthier recently a
2016 World Food Prize with the word - a
group of scientists who developed a
unique GMOs sweet potato that was
enriched with vitamin A and this who
potatoes actually originally developed
for area set-based food insecurity while
the original intent of some of these
genetically modified crops is to address
issues of malnutrition and food
insecurity
I'm all for more nutrient-dense
vegetables on my plate international
bodies like the World Health
Organization agree the GMOs on the
international market has passed rigorous
safety assessments and are not likely to
present any kind of risk to human health
well I heard that GMOs are not tested
for safety or nutrition and I want not
that let me stop you right there
genetically modified foods in Canada go
through rigorous checks and tests to
ensure nutrient value and safety in
Canada it takes about seven to ten years
of rigorous testing for any kind of GMO
crops can make it to the marketplace and
onto your dinner table international
bodies like the World Health
Organization agree that GMOs from
countries with regulatory bodies on the
international market have passed safety
acceptance and are not likely to present
any kind of risk to human health
well IR they're not doing any more tests
what's up with that yes there is being a
lot of public concern over this but
Health Canada isn't doing any more
long-term Studies on the safety of GMOs
only because they just don't see GU
notes as being any different from all
the other foods out there and that's
probably where the critique is coming
from ok well I'm still worried don't
make us allergy there might be an
overall rise in allergies and yes some
foods trigger allergies more than others
but
that reviewed hundreds of studies on
GMOs found no relationship whatsoever
between ending GMOs and the rise in
allergies sure there's other factors
that might be able to explain the rise
in allergies but right now we're not
pointing the finger at GMOs
well let's get real you're a bee aren't
all of these studies biased because
they're funded by big food because they
want you to eat their toxic crap
yes biotech companies do fund research
occasionally but that doesn't mean that
they can just alter the results plus
there's now a ton of independent
research groups that have been studying
GMOs and have found comparable results
doesn't that make you feel better
Debbie's but we're killing the bees with
the GMOs what else am I going to put all
my food free or feeling don't do those
bread okay honey lovers you can relax
here's what we know one study exposed
honeybees to 15 times the dose of a
variety of bacteria that famine GMOs and
no death in the honeybees occurred
another study concluded that GMO pollen
and nectar were not harmful to honeybee
theater so I think we're good on that
front so guys here's the bottom line
this is all really just food for thought
I'm not a radical on either side of the
fence I really just don't feel strongly
that there's any kind of strong good
evidence out there against GMOs but I'm
still waiting on my toast to see what
potentially some of those long-term
effects are and I wish was easier to get
that long-term information ultimately as
a dietitian my stance and perspective is
just get more vegetables and fruits in
your diet in general I don't care if
they're GMO or not if you're still
unsure and you want to avoid GMOs for
whatever reason the only real way to do
that is to look for organics oh no i'll
even think about non-organic food now
there are combat mattoon so many foods
to cut out so hungry no I didn't say
that
steady we'll have to save that one for
and not
video well guys I hope you enjoyed this
video and learned a lot I would love to
know your thoughts on GMOs who
definitely leave me a comment below if
you liked this video give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on a bee skips
[Music]